this goofy creature is the biggest bony
fish on earth the ocean sunfish it's
essentially a swimming face I guess that
grows to over 10 feet long and 5,000
pounds it's hard to believe from the
looks of it but it's actually related to
the puffer fish long ago its ancestors
wandered away from the reefs into the
open ocean the enormous won't do you no
good nohow if you're looking for shelter
in a reef but after wandering out to sea
it was able to grow to staggering
proportions and oddly enough it's
fueling that growth by eating jellyfish
one of the most calorie poor critters in
the ocean which kind of makes them like
the rice cakes of the sea like a 1
calorie per ounce kind of calorie for
jellyfish and not only low in calories
of course sting like crate to counter
this the ocean sunfish has thick
luscious lips which are coated in mucous
intestines - are nice and thick to
handle the onslaught as for reproduction
a mother will release an astonishing 300
million eggs in the water
a world record for gonna T and they're
positively tiny expanding by 60 million
times by the time they're a full-grown
adult so why they're called sunfish well
rid themselves of parasites that come to
the surface and roll over on their sides
for one UV light helps bake the
parasites off while enterprising
seagulls land on the fish and pluck off
still more so there you have it an
actual use for seagulls well that in
caring the peach and James in the Giant
Peach
I guess that's fiction think